So anyways,
you can think from the phenomenological
viewpoint of your experience as a whole
instead of you being a subject in an
objective world.
And so here's another way of.
Here's something that's quite useful.
[inaudible] talked about this because he
was moving towards a phenomenological
perspective later in his life.
The last book he wrote was called
mysterium conjunction us and he talked
about three conjunctions that needed to
take place in order for someone to be
well constituted psychologically.
And you know how piaget talked about
learning that you could not only follow
rules but that you could make rules for
new games as sort of the highest level
of moral development.
I would say you extended the Piagetian
moral continuum up past what piaget had
envisioned.
Now he didn't.
He didn't do that because he wasn't
trying to extend piaget's model,
but.
But you can think about it the same way
and it's not easy to come up with a
moral motive being say,
that transcends the ability to make
rules for new games.
That's damn smart man.
That's,
that's,
that's a major home run by piaget as far
as I'm concerned.
But Young said something like this said,
look,
when you're going through the process of
psychological integration,
here's a way of conceptualizing it,
and he thought about this as
symbolically as male,
female pairings,
because as I've tried to point out the
most,
one of the most fundamental character
categories that are mythological
imagination uses to structure the world
is the category of masculine and
feminine.
And it moves that around.
You know,
it's,
it's a fundamental metaphor.
So you can move that around anywhere.
And so young thought,
well,
one of the things that you're trying to
do is to get your thoughts and your
emotions integrated.
And so,
you know,
the Classic Enlightenment Viewpoint,
roughly speaking,
is something like passion is the enemy
of reason,
right?
And so to the degree that your rational,
it's sort of afraid of viewpoint.
It's because he got your emotions under
control and there's some truth in that,
but not enough truth.
I like the psg an idea better,
which is that,
no,
that isn't what happens.
What happens if you're playing the
proper game is that you integrate your
emotions underneath.
You're thinking something like that.
So they're all working in the same
direction,
you know.
So for example,
you can make your anxiety work against
you or for you.
And one of the ways I get it,
I made a program called the future
authoring program that I think helps
people do that because one of the things
you see when you're talking to people
and they're trying to solve problems is
that they're afraid to face the problem
and so then their anxiety is working
against them and you can think about it
as a,
as antagonistic to rationality,
but then I could say,
well,
why don't you think for awhile about
what your life would be like if you
didn't face this problem?
Because if you think that through,
if you have a problem and you really
think through what the consequences are
going to be in three to five years of
not facing it,
then you're going to get more afraid of
not it then facing it.
And that's great because then your
anxiety,
instead of standing in front of you,
instead of you having a dragon guarding
the path in front of you,
will you have one chasing you down the
path from behind?
That's a lot more useful.
And so you know,
that's just a minimal example of the
utility of getting your emotions and
your and your thoughts aligned the same
way.
The same thing happens with aggression.
You know,
one of the most common reasons that
people come and seek psychotherapy
really is because they're too agreeable.
But what that means is they're not
assertive enough.
They haven't integrated their capacity
for aggression and so other people can
push them around and,
and there are very conflict avoidant and
and so the consequences of that across
time is that you don't stand up for
yourself well enough and you get taken
advantage of and that spirals badly
downward.
And so partly what you do when you're
doing assertiveness training with people
is you find out what they're angry about
and there are usually angry,
angry if they're not assertive enough
because other people are taking
advantage of them or you could say
because they're not putting their own
necessities forward with enough force.
It's hard to distinguish between those
two things.
But anyways,
you know,
you get them to talk about what they're
angry about that often makes them cry
often many times.
And then you get them to kind of
envision what they would want to have
instead,
which they're often afraid to do because
people are afraid to think about what
they want because that makes it more
clear when they're not getting it.
And that's painful,
right?
Or maybe they're afraid of hoping so
they won't specify a clear aim.
But anyways,
you get them to think about what they
might want.
Instead you get them to think about the
costs of not pursuing that.
And then you help them develop
strategies for integrating their
aggression and with their thinking so
that they can come up with a plan to
approach the world.
In a more confident way,
so for example,
someone might come to me and say,
I'm being bullied badly at work,
and so then I'll say,
well,
what are your options?
You have to put up with it.
Well,
we'll,
we'll figure that out because maybe you
do.
Maybe you don't have options,
but here's how to find out.
Get your damn cv together so it's
pristine,
right?
It's,
it's ready to go.
Get over your fear of a new interview
because it people are generally afraid
of that.
Get over your fear of applying for a new
job.
Start thinking about what it would mean
to have a different job.
to have a better job even because maybe
your fear is just making you stuck here,
but I can tell you one thing.
If someone's picking on you at work and
you don't have options,
you lose so you get the person to start
building a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
if you're going to tell this person to
stop,
you have to know how to make them stop
and one and the one thing you need for
sure is an option.
And if you can't,
if you don't have an option,
then maybe we start thinking about the
fact that you need some more training or
something like that because you cannot
negotiate if you don't have any power.
So because while,
especially if you're dealing with
someone who's really out to get you or
really disagreeable,
if you don't have a leg to stand on,
they'll just push you over and maybe
they'll jump on youtube because that's
what they're like and they enjoy it
anyway.
So it's no joke.
So you put your options behind you and
then you start to think about strategy.
So I tell people,
look,
if you're being harassed at work,
you documented every time it happens and
you write it down so you've got like 20
stories about it and it's fully
documented and then you go confront the
person at some point,
but with at least three pieces of
evidence and you have some sense of what
you tell them about what will happen if
they don't stop.
So you have to figure out,
well,
if they don't stop,
what are you gonna do about it?
Leave.
Not if you can't leave.
So you,
you have to be able to wield a big stick
and speak softly,
but you see that way.
It's.
That's how you take your aggression,
which is an absolutely necessary part of
your psyche and manifest it up into a
sophisticated means of dealing with the
world.
You don't just suppress it.
You say,
well,
I should be able to put up with it,
or I wish I wasn't so angry or
something.
It's like,
forget that.
That's all that'll happen is your blood
pressure will stay high and you'll die
of a heart attack.
Because anger for example,
is a very toxic emotion and it does
cause heart damage over time.
It's the only emotion that we really
know that's been linked to things like
cardiovascular risk and anger is is
toxic because it's like you're driving a
car.
You've.
You're stepping on the gas and pushing
on the brake at the same time because
anger tells you to run away and to
attack at the same time because you
don't know what's gonna happen and so
it.
It really amps up the physiological
demand on your body.
And so if you are including your heart
and your musculature,
so if you stay like that for like 10
years,
you know you're going to age 20 years
and that's a bad plan.